[Música]
y llegamos al momento de repasar la
prensa internacional hoy 25 de julio con
rosa parés más deuda en el estudio rosa
bienvenida muy buen día feliz inicio de
semana vamos abrir entonces esta revista
de prensa con la explicación de una
medida que nos afecta a nosotros también
como medio de comunicación público
francés esa supresión del canon llamado
la rave en down tele que financiaba a
los medios audiovisuales públicos rosa
bueno es de aragón exactamente tal y
como nos cuenta media parte en el
artículo que hemos seleccionado resulta
que el pasado sábado 23 de julio como
dice media parte en medio de un clima
estival en estos momentos en que nadie
acaba de prestar mucha atención a las
sesiones parlamentarias los diputados de
la mayoría es de tierra de la plataforma
de macrón del presidente con el partido
los republicanos la derecha más
conservadora recordemos y con la
agrupación nacional la extrema derecha
liderada por marine lepén aprobaron la
supresión de la contribución para el
audiovisual público este era un canon un
impuesto que era la principal vía de
financiación
de los medios audiovisuales públicos
hablamos de la radio y de la televisión
pública francesa entre las que se
cuentan france televisión france radio
tv salmón franz media mont que es de la
que formamos parte france24 ina y arte
entre otras bien precisamente para
sustituirlo parece que se va a
reemplazar esta partida económica con
una parte de lo recaudado con el iva sin
embargo el valor exacto puede ir
cambiando en función de cada gobierno
raúl rosa cuáles son los argumentos de
los que votaron por la supresión y lo
escoltaron en contra digamos para
entender un poco tener un poco de más
contexto bien pues esta votación se
realizó este es un artículo la supresión
de este canon es un artículo dentro de
la ley de poder adquisitivo y lo que
pone de manifiesto esta votación es como
macrón se está liando antes con la
derecha con los republicanos y con la
extrema derecha la agrupación nacional
para pasar
e iniciativas legislativas después de
perder su mayoría en la asamblea
nacional recordemos antes que con la
izquierda y precisamente es que
recordemos que los partidos que han
votado a favor de esta supresión y que
finalmente la han conseguido eso sí en
la asamblea nacional la plataforma de
macrón los republicanos y la agrupación
nacional han argumentado que su
intención es aumentar el poder
adquisitivo de los franceses sin embargo
recordemos también que estos tres
partidos votaron en contra de aumentar
el salario mínimo interprofesional
viena en boca del gobierno su intención
es suprimir los impuestos que pesan
sobre los franceses una tasa recordemos
que supone un gasto de unos 11 euros
mensuales para los hogares que la pagan
por otro lado
la extrema derecha abiertamente marín de
penn dice que su intención sería
privatizar tanto radio france como franz
televisión una
la propuesta que comentamos en campaña y
en boca de una diputada de agrupación
nacional carolyn parmentier dijo una
gran democracia como la nuestra no
necesita el servicio público bien por
otro lado la izquierda no la nube sí que
se opuso a éstas a la supresión de esta
tasa de hecho dijo que era un ataque
contra la independencia de los medios de
comunicación público respecto a los
poderes económicos y a los poderes
políticos y dijo que en estos momentos
no precisamente de gran concentración de
los medios privados de la prensa sobre
todo en manos de multimillonarios era un
momento en que se necesita más que nunca
el servicio público rosa y la tv tf1 a
su breve repaso por la historia de este
canon y el huffingtonpost también de la
movilización en contra de esta medida
protagonizada por los profesionales de
la información exactamente bien
empezamos por esta breve historia esta
fue una medida un canon que se implantó
en 1933 hace prácticamente 9 años en un
primer momento para financiar la radio
obviamente luego pasó a financiar
también la televisión y de hecho como
adelantábamos los hogares que la pagan
son aquellos que tienen dispositivos de
radio y de televisión en un momento
online cuando era presidente pretendió
ampliar esta tasa también a los hogares
con ordenadores y smartphones una medida
que sin embargo quedó enterrada quedó en
el olvido y como decíamos en la campaña
de 2022 tanto macrón como demora este
candidato también de extrema derecha
como marine lepén propusieron eliminarla
por lo que han votado a favor de esta
supresión como decíamos en la asamblea
nacional ahora queda ver cómo acaba esta
historia porque tiene que pasar todavía
por el senado y la coalición de
izquierda a lanús como decíamos que se
opuso a esta supresión dijo también que
la llevaría ante el consejo
constitucional porque considera como
decíamos que ataca a la independencia
del servicio público y precisamente esto
es lo que alegan los periodistas y los
trabajadores del audiovisual público
de hecho el huffington post' recoge un
vídeo que se publicó el 20 de julio en
que distintas caras conocidas de la
televisión y de la radio pública
francesa de france de françois ponen
hacen preguntas a los espectadores para
que se hagan cargo de lo que supondría
eliminar el servicio público y la labor
periodística que realiza como decíamos
independiente en condiciones normales
del poder político y del económico y
lanzando en preguntas a la audiencia
como las siguientes qué pasa si las
personas a las que investigamos son las
que tienen que decidir nuestro
presupuesto o si no fuera en el servicio
público hubieran podido ver una
investigación sobre coca cola mcdonald's
o líder pues lo sabremos
obviamente mientras pasa el tiempo rosa
muchísimas gracias como siempre por toda
la información nos vemos mañana con más
revista pues pasamos a saludar a nuestro
primer invitado al día